Tasha: 灵尊者灵魂核心获得两经验而不是经验
Tasha: The soul core of the Spirit Master gains 2 experience instead of experience.
Tasha: 如果战斗社保将额外获得3经验
Tasha: If the battle is successful, you gain an extra 3 experience.
Tasha: 如果不存在
Tasha: If it doesn't exist,
Tasha: 一肥或二肥
Tasha: One fat or two fat?
Tasha: 什么意思
Tasha: What does that mean?
Shure: 拆快递
Shure: Unbox the package.
Nicous: 草 吉星来了
Nicous: Damn, the lucky star is here.
Tasha: 3级
Tasha: Level 3.
Nicous: 1级对不起让你失望了
Nicous: Level 1, sorry to disappoint you.
Tasha: 要3级然后走连败
Tasha: Need to be level 3 and then go on a losing streak.
Nicous: ok
Nicous: Okay.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Nicous: 搞这么复杂吗
Nicous: Why make it so complicated?
Nicous: 你的i  正负多少
Nicous: What's your i positive or negative?
Lucia: 你在找什么
Lucia: What are you looking for?
Jake: 没有在晃悠
Jake: Just wandering around.
Jake: 开工吧
Jake: Let's get to work.
Nicous: 开工了
Nicous: Let's get to work.
Jake: 上班了上班了
Jake: Time to work, time to work.
Jake: 拆快递 2楼可能得收拾收拾
Jake: Unbox the package. The second floor might need some tidying up.
Jake: 你们今天做狗吗
Jake: Are you guys going to be dogs today?
Jake: 今天看狗吗
Jake: Are you watching dogs today?
Lucia: 平时可以做
Lucia: Normally we can do it.
Lucia: 到底是做狗还是看狗啊
Lucia: So are we being dogs or watching dogs?
Jake: 都可以做
Jake: We can do both.
Jake: 可以看看狗
Jake: We can watch dogs.
Jake: 要不我们建立一些逻辑吧
Jake: Why don't we establish some logic first.
Jake: 作为一个
Jake: As a...
Jake: 这个也是什么f人还是什么人
Jake: This is what kind of F person or whatever.
Jake:建立一些逻辑先看狗
Jake: Establish some logic, watch dogs first.
Shure: 噢
Jake: 然后按照狗去做狗
Jake: Then act like dogs according to the dogs.
Lucia: 建立逻辑是替人
Lucia: Establishing logic is for people.
Jake: 替人好
Jake: For people is good.
Shure: 哎哟 腰好痛
Shure: Oh, my back hurts.
Katrina: 那就是先小说看一点狗的款式
Katrina: Then let's read a bit about dog styles first.
Nicous: 什么时候做狗
Nicous: When are we being dogs?
Katrina:  然后开始选择
Katrina: Then start choosing.
Nicous: 做狗
Nicous: Being dogs.
Lucia: 我需要一支笔
Lucia: I need a pen.
Jake:做狗就是他们会有一个一条纸板
Jake: When making a dog, they will have a piece of cardboard.
Shure: 就是正在做狗
Shure: Just making a dog.
Lucia:  就是只要只要能只要能画个大概就行
Lucia: As long as you can draw a rough outline, it's fine.
Jake:然后把纸板变成狗
Jake: Then turn the cardboard into a dog.
Lucia: 头暂时还不需要过多考虑
Lucia: For now, don't worry too much about the head.
Lucia: 哦   点
Lucia: Oh, point.
Tasha: 三阶段就能卡着利息升8级我靠
Tasha: At stage three, you can hold onto the interest to reach level 8, oh my god.
Shure: 我们要做狗 我们就要当告密者
Shure: If we want to be dogs, we have to be informants.
Lucia: 在我的眼镜突然被转歪的时候
Lucia: When my glasses suddenly got twisted.
Shure: smith懂不
Shure: Do you understand, Smith?
Lucia: AI会不会以为地震了
Lucia: Will AI think it's an earthquake?
Jake: 那可能地震频率过高
Jake: Maybe the earthquake frequency is too high.
Lucia: 是不是个好问题
Lucia: Is that a good question?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 也没有很经常吧
Lucia: It doesn't happen very often, right?
Jake: 好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 我只是刚才突然转到线了而已
Lucia: I just suddenly turned the line just now.
Jake: 那没电了
Jake: Then it's out of battery.
Jake: 确实和地震差不多
Jake: It's really like an earthquake.
Lucia: 我需要一根笔老板
Lucia: I need a pen, boss.
Jake: 什么笔
Jake: What kind of pen?
Lucia: 随便什么笔
Lucia: Any pen.
Lucia: 能在纸箱上面画出来线就行
Lucia: As long as it can draw a line on the cardboard.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 还有我们之前买的彩笔是还没到吗
Jake: And the colored pens we bought earlier haven't arrived yet?
Lucia: 好我们已经实现无纸化工作了
Lucia: Well, we've already gone paperless.
Lucia: 现在没有笔是吧
Lucia: So no pens now, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 是没到是吧
Jake: They haven't arrived, right?
Shure: 我们要不要臆想出来一只纸狗
Shure: Should we imagine a paper dog?
Lucia: 因为我害怕一直用这白板笔
Lucia: Because I'm afraid if we keep using this whiteboard pen.
Lucia: 给他用没墨了
Lucia: It will run out of ink.
Jake: 嗯买买买
Jake: Mm, buy, buy, buy.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake: 所以没到还是还是怎么回事
Jake: So, did it arrive or not?
Jake: 之前买的这个
Jake: The ones we bought earlier.
Lucia:笔吗
Lucia: Pens?
Katrina: 刚到刚到菜鸟驿站
Katrina: Just arrived at the Cainiao pickup station.
Jake: 哦那就还能领是吧
Jake: Oh, so we can pick them up.
Jake: 今天还能
Jake: We can still do it today.
Jake: 今天就能拿到了
Jake: We can get it today.
Jake: 催他们一下
Jake: Hurry them up a bit.
Lucia: 雨轩有那种普通的写字的笔
Lucia: Rainy has those regular writing pens,
Lucia: 但是我感觉往完了纸上可能有点
Lucia: but I feel like they might be a bit...
Lucia: 有点细好做标记的话所以
Lucia: A bit too thin to make marks, so...
Jake: 那就去取快递
Jake: Then go pick up the delivery.
Tasha: 他虽然能上7个人
Tasha: Even though it can accommodate 7 people,
Tasha: 但是的卡牌里面的那个概率还是那个
Tasha: the probability in the card is still the same...
Tasha: 那个等级概率啊
Tasha: The level probability, yeah.
Jake: 走把二楼给收拾收拾给你们跳舞
Jake: Let's go clean up the second floor so you guys can dance.
Shure:  二楼有什么
Shure: What's on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼有饺子
Jake: There are dumplings on the second floor.
Shure:  中午吃的饭还没收那什么
Shure: The lunch we had hasn't been cleaned up yet.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 找点事做
Jake: Let's find something to do.
Shure:  从何下手
Shure: Where do we start?
Shure: 这饼怎么都啃一半一半的
Shure: Why are all these cakes half-eaten?
Jake:是俺硬撕的
Jake: I tore them up.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Okay.
Jake:先放这 一会
Jake: Put it here for now.
Jake:看心情在吃
Jake: Eat it later if you feel like it.
Shure: 哎哟 我草
Shure: Ouch, damn.
Jake:不知道有点瞎
Jake: Didn't know it was so dark.
Shure: 是的 说明这个眼镜的
Shure: Yeah, it means these glasses...
Jake:带来了一些基变
Jake: Brought some changes.
Shure: 透光率不好
Shure: The light transmittance is bad.
俢硕: 当然有可能是佩戴者的问题
Shure: Or it could be the wearer's problem.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 但是暂且不考
Jake: But let's not think about that for now.
俢硕：ok 默认佩戴者都是正常人类是吧
Shure: Okay, let's assume the wearer is a normal human, right?
Jake: 这地方能变成KTV吗
Jake: Can this place be turned into a KTV?
Shure:  可以
Shure: Yes, it can.
Shure:  可以变
Shure: It can be transformed.
Nicous: 这简直是春天来了
Nicous: It's like spring has come.
Shure:  变KTV的话需要需要来一个麦克
Shure: If we want to turn it into a KTV, we need a microphone.
Jake:那没有
Jake: We don't have that.
Jake: 确实要一个麦
Jake: We do need a mic.
Jake: 这麦插哪插电脑上
Jake: Where do we plug it in, into the computer?
Shure:  对可以插在电脑上
Shure: Yeah, you can plug it into the computer.
Jake: 我们把这玩意剪成综艺会被骂死应该
Jake: If we cut this into a variety show, we'll get scolded to death.
俢硕: 为什么
Shure: Why?
Jake:就是浪费的东西
Jake: It's just a waste of stuff.
Jake: 现在一般综艺上面是不是都要
Jake: Don't all variety shows nowadays...
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 就是都会特地标一个
Jake: ...specifically point out...
Shure: 对就是什么没浪费的
Shure: Yeah, like nothing is wasted.
Shure:  给剧组人员全吃了
Shure: Everything is eaten by the crew.
Nicous: 哦
Nicous: Oh.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Shure: 那我们这这么给剧组人员吃是吗
Shure: So, are we going to let the crew eat all this?
Nicous: 没说这些东西都是给 哦哟
Nicous: Didn't say all this stuff is for... oh wow.
Shure: 喂给流浪猫了
Shure: Fed it to the stray cats.
Nicous: 喂给流浪小狗吃了
Nicous: Fed it to the stray dogs.
Jake: 哦真的 走我们喂狗去
Jake: Oh really? Let's go feed the dogs.
Shure: 惨
Shure: Poor thing.
Shure: 他比咱吃的好说实话哈哈
Shure: Honestly, they eat better than us. Haha.
Shure: 那只狗比我命应该金贵
Shure: That dog probably has a better life than me.
Jake: 但是你可以玩了
Jake: But you get to play.
Shure: 哦 那到是
Shure: Oh, that's true.
Shure: 死
Shure: Dead.
Shure: 强行下强度
Shure: Forcing the intensity.
Jake: 然后我们一会把这桌子给搬空
Jake: Then we'll clear this table in a bit.
Jake: 搬到墙角墙边
Jake: Move it to the corner.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 是要对这个桌子进行一下清理吗
Shure: Do we need to clean this table up?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 还有什么垃圾要扔吗
Jake: Any other trash to throw away?
Shure: 这有根筷子
Shure: There's a chopstick here.
Jake: 对进行一些适当清理
Jake: Yeah, do a bit of cleaning.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Alice:厨房湿巾呢
Alice: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼下
Shure: Downstairs.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Nicous: 哦靠6个人的五毒圣剑
Nicous: Oh wow, six people's Poisonous Sword.
Nicous: 尽然打不到她半个人头
Nicous: Couldn't even hit half a person.
Jake: 谢彬竹急了
Jake: Xie Binzhu is anxious.
Shure: 他急了
Shure: He's anxious.
Shure: 他很急
Shure: He's very anxious.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 好困
Shure: So sleepy.
Shure: 没睡够
Shure: Didn't get enough sleep.
Shure: 你急什么
Shure: Why are you in such a hurry?
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina:  你买那个钟
Katrina: You bought that clock.
Lucia: 是干嘛的
Lucia: What's it for?
Jake: 那个钟就是每一层放一个
Jake: That clock is for placing one on each floor.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 就是每一帧都知道时间对不对
Jake: So you can know the time at each frame, right?
Jake: 就是可以测试用
Jake: It's for testing.
Jake: 其实每一帧都是有时间
Jake: Actually, every frame has a time.
Jake: 就是对一下
Jake: Just to check.
Lucia: 理论上说拍电影是应该这样的
Lucia: Theoretically, that's how filming should be.
Lucia: 不过我鉴于我们这个不是电影所以
Lucia: But considering we're not making a movie.
Jake: 哎你看过的对吧
Jake: Hey, you've seen it, right?
Tasha: 看过了嗯
Tasha: Yes, I've seen it.
Lucia: 我觉得就他吧
Lucia: I think it's just him.
Lucia: 撕下来
Lucia: Tear it off.
Tasha: 我打不过你
Tasha: I can't beat you.
Nicous: 你别又打不过我
Nicous: Don't tell me you can't beat me again.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Nicous: 你刚刚才赢的
Nicous: You just won.
Tasha: 你赢不是好吗
Tasha: Isn't it good that you won?
Tasha: 你看我打不过你
Tasha: See, I can't beat you.
Nicous: 才多久啊
Nicous: How long has it been?
Jake: 你们两个人只能交锋一次是吗
Jake: You two can only face off once, right?
Nicous: 哎哟 我草 我破防了
Nicous: Ouch, damn, I'm broken.
Jake: 骂游戏了
Jake: Cursing at the game.
Jake: 是吧你看
Jake: Right, see?
Lucia: 我说他浅浅的破防哈哈哈
Lucia: I said he barely broke.
Nicous: 就是你跟我说撸把撸把
Nicous: You told me to play, to play.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Nicous: 撸把没关系可以玩
Nicous: It's okay to play.
Tasha: 可以玩
Tasha: It's okay to play.
Nicous: 就玩成这样子了
Nicous: Just ended up like this.
Tasha: 你看你还在第一名呢
Tasha: See, you're still in first place.
Tasha: 这不是一个好兆头吗
Tasha: Isn't that a good sign?
Nicous:  我草你刚拆我的背景当狗擦
Nicous: Damn, you just tore down my background like a dog.
Tasha: 哎我刚刚也被人破防了一次
Tasha: I just got broken once too.
Tasha:还好吧我刚刚才6级
Tasha: It's okay, I was just level 6.
Nicous: 还好是哪个人我给他
Nicous: Luckily, who was it that I gave it to?
Tasha: 叫蛰伏他已经走了
Tasha: Called Zhefu, he's already gone.
Nicous:  我草
Nicous: Damn it.
Katrina:  我这一层是厚的
Katrina: This layer is thick.
Katrina:  之前压的花瓣
Katrina: The petals were pressed before.
Jake:我也要喝
Jake: I want to drink too.
Katrina:  这一层试验品
Katrina: This layer is experimental.
Shure: 这镜子怎么感觉会把人照得显高
Shure: Why does this mirror make people look taller?
Tasha: 你知道我要上10级了吗马上
Tasha: You know I'm about to reach level 10 soon.
Tasha: 马上哈哈
Tasha: Soon, haha.
Nicous: 我没有托了
Nicous: I don't have support anymore.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Nicous: 这神奇的第一把真的让我恶心
Nicous: This magical first game really disgusts me.
Shure: 你就打吧
Shure: Just play.
Jake: 上面桌子搬完了吗
Jake: Is the table upstairs moved?
Nicous: 擦好了 把桌子移开了
Nicous: It's wiped clean. The table's been moved.
Shure:  擦完了
Shure: It's wiped.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  狗你得
Katrina: Dog, you have to...
Alice:狗在哪呢
Alice: Where's the dog?
俢硕：狗在咖啡店
Shure: The dog's at the café.
Alice:咖啡店在哪
Alice: Where's the café?
Katrina:  对它还没进行社会化训练
Katrina: It hasn't gone through socialization training yet.
Shure:  对它会咬你
Shure: Yeah, it might bite you.
Katrina:  对啊但它没长啥牙
Katrina: Yeah, but it doesn't have many teeth yet.
Alice:多大
Alice: How old is it?
Shure: 我的放在微波炉前
Shure: Mine is in front of the microwave.
Shure: 我们不要搞混
Shure: Let's not mix them up.
Shure: 我的放在微波炉前
Shure: Mine is in front of the microwave.
Shure: 那个那什么
Shure: That, that thing...
Shure: 北冰洋
Shure: Beibingyang.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  还有一个
Shure: There's one more.
Shure: ok
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 转过来是吧
Shure: Turn it around, right?
Jake: flower
Jake: Flower.
Shure:  然后我们现在要用二层干嘛
Shure: So what are we going to do with the second layer now?
Jake:回头你们要跳舞
Jake: Later, you guys have to dance.
俢硕: 啊
Shure: What?
俢硕: 我差点忘了
Shure: I almost forgot.
Shure:  我们还有这么重要任务
Shure: We still have such an important task.
Jake: 你们还有重要任务
Jake: You guys have an important task.
Katrina:  嗯这花怎么会有黏黏的东西
Katrina: Hmm, why is there sticky stuff on this flower?
Shure: 我们是要又要去练团了是吗
Shure: Are we going to practice with the band again?
Katrina:  你可以先学
Katrina: You can start learning first.
Shure:  不行我不能投入大
Shure: No, I can't fully commit.
Shure:  大家卷我绝对不是这样的人
Shure: I'm definitely not the type to push others hard.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's wrong?
Tasha: 狠狠把他暴打了
Tasha: Beat him up really hard.
Tasha: 现在开始
Tasha: Starting now.
Katrina: 他下来了呵
Katrina: He's coming down, huh.
Katrina:  他来了
Katrina: Here he comes.
俢硕：人家不爆杀你嘛
Shure: Isn't he going to kill yo
Shure:  随便杀他装备都没上呢
Shure:  略施小计就把你玩的团团转谢彬竹
Shure:  你就是这样被女人玩弄的
Shure:  是不是
Tasha: 什么
Shure: 哎
Lucia: 哎就唱给你吧
Lucia: Hey, I'll sing it for you.
Shure: 太简单了
Shure: That's too easy.
Katrina:  你最后一天啥活动来着
Katrina: What are your plans for the last day?
Katrina:  你怎么不用干活呢
Katrina: How come you don't need to work?
Lucia: 哎搞点
Lucia: Just doing some stuff.
Shure:  我最后一天什么活动
Shure: What are my plans for the last day?
Shure:  我是一个
Shure: I am a...
Katrina:  是每个人都要有个ID啊
Katrina: Everyone needs an ID, right?
Lucia: 我想看看这个
Lucia: I want to see this.
俢硕: all nice
Shure: All nice.
Lucia: 这个这
Lucia: This one, this...
Lucia: 比如说这层放完剩下再放一层纸是吗
Lucia: So after placing this layer, we add another paper layer, right?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 再放一层干燥板
Katrina: Then add a drying board.
Katrina:  再放一层纸
Katrina: Then add another paper layer.
俢硕: 我我是建立这个经济体系的人嘛
Shure: I am the one who established this economic system, you know.
Shure:  你忘记了吗
Shure: Did you forget?
Katrina:  哦哦
Katrina: Oh, right.
Katrina:  明白了
Katrina: Got it.
Shure:  我的唯一任务就是把货币做出来
Shure: My only task is to create the currency.
Katrina:  货币已经买了
Katrina: The currency has been bought.
Shure:  OK解决
Shure: OK, problem solved.
Shure:  伟大无需多言
Shure: Greatness needs no words.
Jake: 落地了是吧
Jake: It's implemented, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:伟大的构想
Jake: Great concept.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  你知道我国第一个货币叫做什么吗
Shure: Do you know what the first currency of our country was called?
Shure:  让我
Shure: Let me...
Alice: 修币
Jake:修币
Jake: Shure coin.
Shure:  那出出现在哪个哪个朝代
Shure: And which dynasty did it appear in?
Jake: 包比比
Jake: Bao Bi Bi.
Shure:  宋代的骄子是我国第一个出现的纸币
Shure: The Jiaozi of the Song Dynasty was the first paper currency in our country.
Jake: 哪真的呀这是
Jake: Really, is that true?
Alice:没见过姣子只见过饺子
Alice: I've never seen Jiaozi, only dumplings.
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure:  需要帮忙吗
Shure: Need any help?
Katrina:  还有一个板你想做也可以做
Katrina: There's one more board, you can do it if you want.
Lucia: 在这边吗
Lucia: Is it over here?
Katrina:  什么你要板吗
Katrina: What, you want a board?
Lucia: 对刚才
Lucia: Yes, just now.
Katrina: 来吧用掉吧
Katrina: Go ahead, use it up.
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Lucia: 明明记得刚才在这边有
Lucia: I clearly remember it was here just now.
Lucia: 但是这样吧找不到了
Lucia: But now, I can't find it.
Katrina:  夹汉堡包
Katrina: Grabbing a burger.
Tasha: 我觉得利桑卓在这个版本最厉害
Tasha: I think Lissandra is the strongest in this version.
Tasha: 5费卡里面
Tasha: Among the 5-cost cards.
Tasha: 那刀妹和猴子的话就猴子厉害点吧
Tasha: Between Irelia and Wukong, Wukong is a bit stronger.
Katrina:  唉哟我直接用新的吧
Katrina: Ah, I'll just use a new one.
Tasha: 拿个什么呢
Tasha: What should I take?
Lucia: 太厚了的话我改变一下策略
Lucia: If it's too thick, I'll change my strategy.
Tasha: 就抢个无敌2把
Tasha: Just grab an invincible 2.
Tasha: 这把我追
Tasha: I'll go for it.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Tasha: 我靠你到底要什么你说嘛
Tasha: Come on, what do you really want?
Nicous: 我都可以反正你准备什么
Nicous: I'm okay with anything, whatever you're preparing.
Tasha: 你可以拿第二的
Tasha: You can take the second.
Tasha: 我可以把第二的位置让给你牌给你
Tasha: I can give you the second position and the cards.
Nicous: 但是我只是想要那个鬼
Nicous: But I just want that ghost.
Shure:  你等他快三星5费的时候你就点了
Shure: When he's almost three-star and 5-cost, you should select it.
Nicous: 肯定点不能让他少了
Nicous: Definitely, can't let him miss it.
Jake: 谢彬竹还能拿个第二啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu can still get second place?
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn.
Jake: 谢彬竹还能拿个第二啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu can still get second place?
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: So amazing.
Nicous: 拿个第二还不轻轻松松
Nicous: Getting second place is easy.
Shure:  说实话
Shure: To be honest.
Shure:  其实其他6个应该都是人机
Shure: Actually, the other six are probably all bots.
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: Really are.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 所以输不过他们
Tasha: So we can't beat them.
Jake: 哦人机很牛逼
Jake: Oh, bots are impressive.
Shure:  不是所以他一个人类都没有几百
Shure: No, so he doesn't have any humans left.
Shure:  他就是人类中的倒数第一
Shure: He's the last among humans.
Nicous: 为什么
Nicous: Why?
Shure:  我们这左侧的这个RGB是干嘛的
Shure: What's this RGB on our left side for?
Jake:你说这个灯吗
Jake: You mean this light?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 它就是光
Jake: It's just a light.
Shure: 那为什么
Shure: Then why...
Jake: 然后分光了
Jake: And it splits the light.
Jake: 它就是白光
Jake: It's just white light.
Jake: 然后它往这边它就它就分了
Jake: Then when it goes over here, it splits.
Tasha: 我谁都打不过
Tasha: I can't beat anyone.
Nicous: 那我直接点
Nicous: Then I'll just select it.
Tasha: 不你为什么不玩第二名
Tasha: No, why don't you play for second place?
Nicous: 没有区别
Nicous: No difference.
Nicous: 第一第二和第三有什么区别
Nicous: What's the difference between first, second, and third?
Nicous: 我直接点
Nicous: I'll just select it.
Tasha:哈哈干嘛呀
Tasha: Haha, why?
Shure: 就不想让她爽
Shure: Just don't want her to enjoy it.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Nicous: 不是我他妈才9级我玩不玩
Nicous: No, damn it, I'm only level 9, should I play or not?
Tasha: 1只两只3只5只
Tasha: One, two, three, five.
Tasha: 这个还差4只
Tasha: This one still needs four.
Shure:  这个什么都想追
Shure: This one wants to pursue everything.
Shure: Shure: 你好贪啊
Shure: Shure: You're so greedy.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What the hell.
Nicous: 追什么我把车卖了让你慢慢追
Nicous: Chase what? I sold the car so you can chase it slowly.
Tasha: 这个不追了
Tasha: Not chasing this one.
Tasha: 就追你们几吧
Tasha: Just chasing after you guys.
Tasha: 这个不追了
Tasha: Not chasing this one.
Tasha: 会有几个了
Tasha: How many will there be?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 还差两个会
Tasha: Still missing two.
Tasha: 还差几个
Tasha: How many are left?
Tasha: 会还差两个
Tasha: Still missing two.
Tasha: 无敌2 无敌2
Tasha: Invincible 2, Invincible 2.
Tasha: 还差3个会
Tasha: Still missing three.
Tasha: 哎三星乌迪尔了
Tasha: Ah, three-star Udyr.
Tasha: 就这样我等等呀
Tasha: Just like this, I'll wait.
Nicous: 点了
Nicous: Clicked it.
Shure:  没有那个是镜像过来的
Shure: No, that's mirrored.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  你不给他装这个了吗
Shure: Aren't you equipping this?
Tasha: 哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 不是我装的
Tasha: I didn't equip it.
Tasha: 这是神器变的
Tasha: It transformed from an artifact.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  what's this
Shure: What's this?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  bomb has been planted是吧
Shure: Bomb has been planted, right?
Shure:  炸弹已经安放
Shure: The bomb has been planted.
Jake: 我靠这东西还能搞闹钟
Jake: Oh my god, this thing can also set an alarm.
Katrina:  你做那小狗呗
Katrina: You make that little dog.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 你帮他做那个小狗
Katrina: Help him make that little dog.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Shure:  今天中午说你做那个小狗呗
Shure: Said at noon you make that little dog.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我把一只两星的卖了
Tasha: I sold a two-star.
Tasha: 在干嘛哈哈哈
Tasha: What are you doing, hahaha.
Nicous: 我他妈的都帮你卖了
Nicous: I sold it for you.
Nicous: 你就这么对我啊
Nicous: And this is how you treat me?
Shure:  教教我这个怎么做哎呀我靠
Shure: Teach me how to do this, oh my god.
Katrina:  这就是汉堡包
Katrina: This is a hamburger.
Nicous: 什么做狗啊
Nicous: What making a dog?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
俢硕；夹花
Shure: Mixed.
Katrina:  做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who can't be a dog?
Shure:  他说他习惯了做狗
Shure: He said he's used to being a dog.
Katrina:  做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who can't be a dog?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 做狗谁不会哈哈哈
Lucia: Who can't be a dog, hahaha.
Katrina:  今天要有太阳就好
Katrina: It'd be nice if it was sunny today.
Tasha: 真的3星了
Tasha: Really, three stars.
Nicous: ok恭喜你而你是我真正的
Nicous: Okay, congrats, you're truly my...
Tasha: 好这个感觉金铲铲
Tasha: Alright, this feels like Gold Shovel.
Tasha: 就是比云顶容易追出来啊
Tasha: It's easier to chase than TFT.
Nicous: 太容易了
Nicous: It's too easy.
Tasha: 哎呀刚刚把装备人全卖了
Tasha: Oh no, I just sold all the gear.
Tasha: 现在搞一搞
Tasha: Let's see what we can do now.
Lucia: 太鼓了
Lucia: Too drumming.
Tasha: 他怎么上不上去装备了
Tasha: Why isn't he equipping it?
Nicous:  靠你上你给的是那个哎
Nicous: Because you gave him that, eh.